one of the reasons why
the bengals are at number 28 is because
of joe burrow wow they would have been
lower they should have been lower they
could have been lower
effect the the joe burrow effect gets
them four bumps in the power rankings
because otherwise they would be number
32 with that 2 and 14 record yeah i mean
listen i get it i you know me mike i you
know he i'm a believer i think he is the
type of personality the guy that's you
know
that type of guy that can change around
an organization
between his play and i think what he'll
be in the locker room and off the field
and you know he's there's an aura about
the kid there's no doubt about that on
the field then off i mean i i watched
him when we were at the combine and i
got to be in the room with him i think
two different times you know there is
he's got a charisma about him you could
see people gravitate towards them
players do and he's a special football
player and i i do i think he's the type
of personality that just you know like a
patrick mahomes doesn't care oh kansas
city hasn't won a super bowl in forever
whatever it is i don't care about the
stigma i'm gonna be awesome and
everybody else hopefully will be awesome
along with me
yeah and and uh look it's gonna take
some time and when you consider where
the bengals currently are they they
didn't accidentally become 2 and 14.
zach taylor's debut season was not good
um how much of it's on him though how
much of it's the talent and how much of
it is that just i mean that look freddie
kittens got fired with a lot better
record than two and 14
elsewhere in the state of ohio how much
do we put on zach taylor for what the
bengals failed to do last year yeah well
i think freddie kitchen's team was uh
significantly more talented than the the
team that zach taylor was coaching so i
don't put a whole lot on him i don't you
know it's you know it's a year where
yeah you took over as the head coach the
team wasn't that talented your best
player on your team and aj green didn't
get to play you know there was offensive
line issues your first round pick and
jonah williams didn't get to play and
then you had a quarterback who you knew
was kind of on his last leg in town
anyways and was gonna have to do
something remarkable to save his job so
i don't put a lot on zach taylor i do
think joe burrow really fits his offense
and i think zach taylor you know knowing
him being around him he's the kind of
guy that's you know will self-evaluate
thyself and he's going to go back to the
drawing board too and look at what do i
need to do to be a better play caller be
more creative and you know mike you look
at it i know you do because we've had
these conversations i mean you look at
their offense on paper i think it would
surprise people you know yeah
quarterback joe mixon arguably one of
the five best running backs in the game
you know and then you start to get into
the wide receiver conversation with aj
green and and boyd and of course if john
ross can stay healthy and then they
draft the t higgins at the top of the
second round you go okay joe burrow and
zach taylor they got some toys to play
with this year and they could be
dangerous
i mean joe mixon is a very good running
back when you don't have an offense
around him when you don't have the pr
protection when you don't have the
passing game to get guys out of the box
that would shut him down he still had a
solid year and uh mixing a guy who could
explode if they get enough help to to
have a true threat in the passing game
and if john ross is healthy if aj green
number seven in your list of receiver
rankings even though he didn't play at
all last year even though he didn't play
at all last year if he can get healthy
and stay healthy i mean it's a couple of
big ifs but that could allow joe mixon
to explode
in year four of his career um and uh
look
that seventh playoff spot that's
available in each conference that makes
teams that otherwise would not have been
contenders contenders especially before
anyone plays a game yeah and and the
bengals if joe burrow
can deliver right away the bengals could
make things interesting very quickly now
how much will the lack of a preseason
yeah joe burrow we're not going to see
him in uniform
against another team right until week
one of the regular season well you know
it's unfortunate yeah the bengals are i
feel bad for them because i do think you
know we talk about all rookie head
coaches rookie head coaches how about a
second year head coach who you know yeah
there was some major turnover in the
team and he's you know still trying to
kind of implement the culture and get
more advanced into his scheme and yeah
you don't get that opportunity but i
think of all the rookie quarterbacks or
any rookie quarterback we've ever seen
right i mean joe burrow playing 15 games
last year that never happens in college
football the fact that he played in the
sec where we know it's loaded with nfl
football players so i don't think he's
going to be shocked and go like oh my
gosh it's the nfl you know he's playing
against nfl players and had him on his
team every week and then i think he's
the biggest advantage he has and you
know not a lot of college quarterbacks
have it he got coached like a pro at lsu
he had joe brady there the offensive
coordinator of the carolina panthers so
a lot of the way he calls plays you know
looks at his own offense reads defenses
with certain these plays is going to be
a lot of carryover it's a similar
offense to zach taylor zach taylor from
sean mcvay you know mcveigh came from
gruden gruden and sean payton have a lot
of the same offensive plays brady you
know joe brady comes from there so he's
gonna he ran a pro-style west coast
offense already and i think the lingo in
the offense is very similar you know two
slants and one offense might have been
bengal now it's lion or whatever it may
be and i think he does have an advantage
as far as other rookies are concerned or
other ones we've seen in the past that
haven't had an off season
who's got the bigger challenge you've
got joe judge with a new head coach with
daniel jones who was a top 10 pick last
year still getting his feet wet in the
nfl and you've got burrow fresh from
college
with a coach who is if anything shell
shocked from what happened to him last
year in cincinnati man yeah they're
they're both tough challenges i guess i
still go with zach taylor here though
you know the thing i'll look about with
joe judge you know he's got some people
around him and a jason garrett dave
gettleman you know and even like i
talked about you know patrick graham
who's been with the patriots and things
like that to where
i think he's got a good support system
and some guys he can lean on a little
bit you know who have been there done
that and especially a jason garrett um
the bengals
yeah i mean zach taylor it's a new
quarterback every day the challenges are
both tough but i guess i give the
advantage there just a little bit of a
tougher challenge to zach taylor i don't
know it's a really tough one to call um
you know zach taylor he can he got the
offense that defense needs to improve
too and that's another side of this
issue where it was the worst run defense
in football last year and all they
really did mike was you know not all but
they signed dj reader you know they got
one guy bigger to go along with geno
atkins and i just wonder if that one guy
will be enough to you know stop some of
the bleeding we saw last year but they
got just absolutely dominated in some
games in the run game
one thing i just realized we failed to
do with the new york giants at number 29
best case worst case let's do it for the
bengals what's the best case scenario
for this team with joe burrow in the
fall he hasn't signed his contract yet
we'll talk about that coming up later in
the program but once he's there and once
he's playing what's the best case
scenario for this team yeah you know i
just i got too many question marks about
that defense and then too many still the
offense is unproven the offensive line i
guess that's the other thing that you
know yeah you know you talked about joe
mixon i don't care who you are running
back you don't have offensive line or
people open up holes you're not going to
go anywhere so you know i really look at
the like the top end cincinnati bengals
maybe flirting with a 500 record but i
think really what i look at is like best
case scenario would be seven and nine
six and ten i really think that that's
that's a positive year for where this
team is at right now you know i don't
think eight and eight i can legitimately
say especially in that division with
those damn three teams they gotta play
holy cow batman that's the problem right
that's the problem that's six losses
right there pretty much look it's not
like they're gonna it's not like they're
gonna lay down against the browns the
ravens and the steelers but they're
gonna be underdogs
at least
at least 10 points against the ravens at
least seven points against the steelers
and at least four points against the
browns maybe more they play the browns
twice in the first half of the season
which makes it even harder because the
browns are closer to a finished product
than the cincinnati bengals you'd rather
get the browns later in the year you'd
rather have some of your you know you
want to have some easy games early to
build some confidence but in a year like
this i mean if it's going to go off the
rails you want to have some games in the
back half of the season where you can
get some wins instead of just being
pounded look at the back half of that
schedule for the bengals there's a lot
of tough games that are lurking for
cincinnati i think the best case is in
that six and ten range yeah i don't
expect them to contend for a playoff
berth the worst case scenario would be
that it's just another disaster and uh
if it's another disaster yeah it's
trouble you have to wonder at what point
zach taylor is in trouble now mike brown
the owner of the bengals does not like
to to pay coaches to not work
so i don't know at what point zack
taylor's contract would make it
financially feasible to move on
but you know at some point you have to
ask yourself uh if they have another
disaster this year
do you go after a joe brady yeah well
they unite him with joe burrow sorry i
didn't mean to cut you off there yeah i
mean i hear you you're right you know
how many years do you give zach taylor
with joe bird well i think the big thing
is here i mean the offense and the
offense has got to excite that fan base
and the nfl a little bit right like a
little bit like you think about kyle
shanahan you know those first two years
underwhelming record wise but i think
the 49er fan base is like yeah i mean
our record wasn't great but our offense
is fun to watch and we were close in
every game and we just they recognized
they needed a player or two just to get
over the hump and then oh damn we're in
the super bowl you know and i think the
same thing for cincinnati like zach
taylor they hired you to be an offensive
genius you go all in don't be afraid
lots of plays ideas be aggressive i
think if he can play that style football
and then even if they ended up four and
12 or three and 13 but everyone went
whoa burro was good t higgins aj green
had a resurgence joe mixon got off this
year then i think that could be one of
those where yeah we went three and 13 or
four and 12. but there's like a light at
the end of the tunnel we kind of liked
what we saw with zach taylor in that
offense and we were fun to watch and joe
burrows
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports